on this episode I go in the startup van
[Music]
[Music]
this is
ask Gary B
[Music]
hey everybody this is gary vay-ner-chuk
and this is episode 192 of the ask gary
vee show live from Dublin Dublin Ireland
and the startup van de rock we've made
it to the startup and gentlemen why
don't you tell everybody who you guys
are what the startup ban is and let's
get into that show yeah of course
well we started to start upon because
tell them who you are I'm Graham this is
Mark and we found it to start off I
think mark was capable arguments who
goes first
whoever gets in there first so basically
if you want to look up Gary Vee you want
to look up Richard Branson there's
thousands of videos but there's these
great entrepreneurs and early stage
startups that the videos are [ __ ] you
know we didn't knock up a video on it's
bad quality pants and noise exterior
noise all kind of stuff that I loved
doing for Wine Library TV [ __ ]
production but you guys wanted to create
an environment this cool band yeah yeah
you could do high quality videos for
them yeah and as a business as a
production company where you would
charge them or as a platform for you
guys to get exposure and build your
brand we said we'd never ever ever
charge the startups because it isn't
fair but you'll shot you'll charge other
people because you're bringing them
value and that's gonna bring you
exposure exactly imagine if you ever had
this spot of Al found
Spotify founders or Elon Musk or sucks
as an original thing all you need is one
lotto ticket and then you build a real
business
exactly I figured it out yeah exactly we
thought we thought we got it but that's
a record so how many have you done by
250 yeah when did you start this last
July yeah every day well we do we do
like volume so we do about 90 in one
night yeah so we started a website and
you just have people come in yeah how
long are they but by 2 or 3 minutes get
in the hitch it's no well you didn't
watch this pitch cuz no one's gonna
listen to 30 40 50 pitches story and
then we kind of trow 10 quick for our
questions yeah people have to learn from
winning this
as well now you guys hustled your way on
to appreciate the hustle I saw it you
know listen Dirac I like to make jokes
about quality of content and things of
that nature but I'd be lying if I didn't
say that I was affected when I took my
little 100th of us I always get hacked
there's a million people right now
trying to hack me to do something in
Helsinki and a million people trying to
hack me a million there's hundreds of
people trying to hack me to do something
in Amsterdam yeah Mexico and theirs they
sit now that might garyvaynerchuk.com
link that up my tour is posted people
trying to figure out ways to get to me
when I looked for a second and that's
what it was yeah I'm like this looks
cool this looks good right and it was
enough to make me for it to do it it
works great well that's what we wanted
to ask you when does a whole so become
annoying yeah you know um it all depends
on a person I'm very good like most
people don't piss me off enough but some
people the second time you ask they're
mad there's a lot of my contemporaries
some of these big names that we all know
that I know get super pissed super
pissed the rocks being super patient
he's the most level of patient all right
let's go there's big arguments going on
yeah yeah well let's go okay so we're
gonna go rushed here we're in an alley
people look like they want to fight
you're gonna wrap it up tell them five
minutes time five minutes let's make it
ten let's go okay yeah so a question did
I have you guys get to play the India
roll this is a big responsibility
India's Irish you got something for you
so question number one yes so we do you
have to have that but he's your personal
questions so yeah yeah so the first one
is when you have to have that
conversation with your dad yes you are
moving away to do your own thing
hey that our conversation go this is a
good question so you know the truth is
this is probably stunning information
for everybody we never really fully had
the talk we kind of had to talk like
three years later believe it or not
really really which is a contradiction
to so many things that I've said to so
many of you like communicate this than
the other thing it was a it was kind of
a weird way we got into it oh okay okay
two minutes we're fine so why don't why
don't we stop at your new bit why we're
gonna no reason to fight
let's we're going ghetto yeah yeah like
I'll finish it yeah so that was
interesting so yeah I mean we innuendo
to it my dad knew was going on but I was
straddling both things the book came out
crush it there was a lot going on my dad
wanted to get more involved in the
business and there's no such thing as
too cooks in the kitchen if I can give
one piece of ice even this yeah are you
the two guys it's not easy no it's you
guys are different dudes you got
different perspectives you could be the
best of friends best intentions love
each other everything vaynermedia I'm
the CEO AJ is the CEO oh I am one he is
too yeah I was one running Wine Library
but it was causing friction between me
and my dad and I thought it was an
opportunity for me to try other things
and an opportunity for my dad to be a
one again okay with my management team
Brandon Bobby just and all those guys
Brant at the time so it felt right and
it worked
my dad was happier and so my dad's an
old-school guy like I over communicate
with my dad but some things you know
family dynamics are tough but it was
great and you know you've seen me I
don't know what episode that is and we
love each other we love each other a lot
maybe we could have had an official
conversation we didn't that's the truth
but um yeah I mean listen I don't
recommend it it was far from my
preference it was just it was learned
behavior over a 15 year period of time
of like how we worked together it was
what was right for our it's why I'm so
scared to give advice on time every
situation is different
work-life balance parenting family
business I give you my stories so I tell
the truth here and now pay for like oh
whoa Gary over communicator but there he
didn't you know trying to give the
truths but that's what happened well
we've got another question here as well
it's what's the best attitude to have if
someone mimics your idea I great you
know tech meetup van you don't own this
idea no no do you the first taxi
confession I mean come on yeah of course
it'd be better yeah
yeah get better guests ask better
questions execute better put out better
micro content like nobody gets to own
these ideas guys yeah we were never
worried you know think will say to us
what's to stop something doing the
startup tram or you're not gonna win
because of the startup van know you it's
a stick it's a cool thing it's cool I
like it anyway but how you interview and
who you get and what you do with that
content is I'm not the first guy to
document my life you know and do a vlog
I'm not the first guy in social but it's
never the first it's the best it's never
the first yeah yeah it's the best the
best yeah the best do you know what I
mean yes what you know you and I don't
get to decide where the minute I know
Dave Wayne oh yeah I've got it that's
the thing yeah yeah since since dailyvee
came out yes people can see and he said
that's why you did it people can see how
hard you work yes and you know whose
work ethic do you respect because that's
how you praise coming from you my
parents your parents worked their faces
off my mom never had him Annie we didn't
have a babysitter ever she had three
kids my mom did everything for us she
regrets raising I'm not I am not even
capable doing my own laundry I'm a slob
my mom picked up everything everything
after me she like you know things that
she likes to joke about but that's what
she wanted to do she did all the work
you know no vacations we didn't know
vacations guys I took three three three
vacations in my life we worked all the
time my dad worked every minute my
parents I'll it's learned behavior by
watching them and probably my own DNA
and so I respect my parents work ethic
and I respect all the single moms and
single dads out there you know life is
complicated I've been thinking a lot
about as I'm starting to build momentum
as somebody whose advice is being taken
seriously that I'm trying to be very
careful because I'm starting to feel a
bigger sense of responsibility yeah and
I'm starting to get nervous to be very
frank with you here I'm giving advice
and tomorrow somebody's uh spouse is
gonna die die I had a distant relative
of you know it hurts very bad he was
diagnosed at 65 or 55 as you can tell
distant try just to remember
I think 65 you know 65 with a cancer and
it was gone in
gun and so what now that kid I know the
kid met him a couple times met about
some family functions his the place is
different now than it was yesterday like
its perspective there's just all these
different barriers right so who do I
respect my parents cuz I know that truth
who else do I respect millions of people
who work really hard to provide because
life gave them a curveball like you can
do everything right and your wife and
kids can go get killed tomorrow by a
truck falling over that on them yeah
yeah yeah and so what you're gonna go
hustle the next day you're gonna grieve
you're gonna adjust you know like so I
don't know I think I think um I respect
anybody who's trying as hard as they can
trying to live the best life they can
trying to do the right things but no
question my work ethic only comes from
two people and I think you guys know
this about me I I don't have any role
models I don't care about you know
Richard Branson and Steve Jobs and Mark
Zuckerberg and Albert Einstein and Bill
Gates none of these people inspire me
they just don't my parents do my and now
and then it flipped into my
responsibility to my friends that worked
for me my brother that works with me the
D rocks of the world and most
importantly which given me unbelievable
scale is the community I I get inspired
by people wanting to take selfies with
me I get inspired with two guys who are
working their butt off in Ireland yeah
who really really wanted me on this show
because it would be good for them to use
my name to get other guests and I like
that yeah yeah I like that or
appreciated my work or a percentage of
both of that or you do know what I mean
there's a lot of ways to get motivated
outside of like like I love that I
motivate people but like I don't think
we need the big names at the top of the
heap to be the motivators yeah well
that's what we decided as well with
startups we were gonna look after every
start that we could interview from
someone who's open from five days ago
broader than two or three years and
they're gone to we go the end of January
who literally came into the van and he
had quit a sport on job that day yeah
and you could see the look at his face
was was fear sure it was good yeah yeah
he knew what he wanted and what to offer
yeah that's great that's great to say
yeah just one more question on that
if you or
start a fun and you were to get one
guest in one guest who did you get it
Mark Zuckerberg Mark Zuckerberg the best
entrepreneur of this generation raining
sure cuz that's instant mark Boone
called us you know what I mean that's
instant go get mark yeah go through the
bonds for you next good we're open the
states soon enough
good real say Sanjay I'm gonna take this
and not this we're coming over that you
know how we gonna get it it's like air
force would know my boundaries are
defined so so we're over there and July
it's gonna be pretty cool yeah thanks so
much you're getting in the startup fun
yeah okay guys you know this is kind of
a unique askgaryvee I'm excited to do
this we had the kind of this tea rocks
kind of yelling at us let's keep them
part where you yelled at st rock I don't
know 1d rock all of a sudden begin the
boss but out we should wrap it up
because we need to catch some flights
and I'm heading over to London now just
had a great talk and Dublin really
enjoying it really enjoying the
evolution of the askgaryvee show
different flavors obviously we'll get
back to kind of our normal track but we
have some guests the other day fun for
you guys to join good luck to you on
your adventures i really kind of did
this very honestly i like their hustle
but what i liked more is i like you more
and so i did this because of knowing
their model of interviewing anybody
here's what i'd like to happen I assume
you have a website where people can just
apply to be a guest on the van right
absolutely and that is what the startup
on Comm great I want all of you have a
startup to go pound them and I expect
them to interview all of you guys
because of the nice gesture I did but
I'm passing on to you guys where the
question got it question of the day word
association
I say Ireland you say you keep asking
questions I'll keep answering them
[Music]